let's jump to the story speaking of
child abuse
hunter biden attributes his penis
obsession to body dysmorphia ah this is
what i was telling you about before yeah
i just i just want to say i think i
think i think hunter biden was abused by
joe for sure
hands down there is something right
there's something weird there's
something insanely messed up about that
family yeah let me tell you
so uh hunter biden said his obsession
with naked selfies was the result of
body dysmorphia according to a rambling
screed found in the notes of his hard
drive i love to be reassured that my
i'm not reading this
i think you have to all right you got to
do it you got to do it all right
strap in everybody here we go
yeah buy the ticket take the ride i love
to be reassured that my nine inch very
big penis was actually big it may sound
funny to you but it's body dysmorphia i
know my penis is almost twice the size
of an average man's penis the first son
wrote on july 12 2018 the note was found
in the hard drive of a laptop biden left
at the delaware i think this dude was
heavily abused by who's he writing the
note to himself his diary entry or to
his dad because they remember when he
sent adult materials to his dad he's i i
missed that yeah it was a link to
pornhub wow and it was sent it was like
a text by just two dads
yikes i think come on when you see
something like that you're like this guy
was abusing his kids well what's what i
would never send porn to mike one of the
most like
that is a controversial take right there
joe well you say that and hunter biden
is watching oh well so
one of the most play wordle yeah it's
not the same
one of the most i think the most
ridiculous things that has had like the
most ridiculous stories that has come
out in the joe biden era
it has to do with with the ashley biden
diary and project veritas they had this
diary
where ashley biden wrote in it that joe
biden
said like abused her sexually
in another way but and and like overtly
and seriously yeah oh yeah like she said
she would say that he would take like
inappropriate showers with it said all
of these nasty things i don't think i'm
sure but the shower thing but what was
beyond that i didn't i can't remember
off the top of my head but it had to be
very like but it had like some nasty it
had nasty things in it and
like they had this diary the new york
times confirmed that this diary was real
and nobody talks about it instead
project veritas journalists get raided
by the fbi over it oh yeah
and that that's then like there is
something seriously seriously wrong
about the biden family and the media
doesn't have videos of joe biden
sniffing little girls like it's it's
right in front of your face it's been in
front of everyone's face for a long time
and so it's not far-fetched to say that
he probably abused hunter
mike hunter is a messed up guy yeah like
everything he's writing about the things
he does the drugs i won't say probably
it's likely i mean i wouldn't be
surprised
yeah was abused i don't know who did it
it could have been joe could have been
joe's brother it could have been a
friend of the family a lot of times it's
a friend of the family here's the thing
though here's the thing about here's the
thing that like counters the argument
that joe who did it was that bo biden
was like a very upstanding human he was
the good son he was like an upstanding
human being he was you know an iraq war
veteran he was an attorney general he
was not messed up in the same way that
hunter biden was well he was supposed to
be the one to take everything over he
was supposed to be the the senator and
the
president and everything like that so i
think everyone's just disappointed that
hunter biden the body man is the one
that's stuck around yeah
that's harsh that's harsh hunter if you
hear this man you got this bro listen
here's the thing i don't i honestly i
feel kind of bad for these guys for
ashley biden and for hunter biden and i
think it's a shame that they
never had the opportunity opportunity to
do anything in their own right really
um but they're treated badly i mean joe
biden treats hunter biden really badly
i've never seen the two interact no but
i mean everything he says about him
constantly saying you know this is the
smartest guy i ever met and then you
read laptop from hell and he's totally
trashing him to his face behind the
scenes literally calling him a pedophile
yeah like horrible stuff you know it's
like he says one thing about his son in
public and everybody knows that he's
saying this other stuff behind the
scenes that would make me feel so
demoralized yeah what did he call peter
pito peter
and like it's like it's sad but at the
same time it's a it's a fair game to
attack it it's fair it's fair game for
us to go after it because like imagine
if this was the trump family but but i'm
not going after anything i'm pointing it
out i mean this is the first son who
calls his dad a child yeah well i'm
saying like the media comes back and
says you're attacking his family why
would you attack his family and it's
like okay imagine this was the trump
family you'd be doing it like they could
have escaped of course he'd have his
door kicked down by the fbi raid and
perp walked you know i i have the things
hundred bucks i i ignore the whinging of
the democratic press
i i try not to ignore when they're lying
outright we can call it their lies but
there's a ton of these democrat
activists who are like
and i'm just like i don't care dude you
know them coming out and being like
don't attack the first family it's like
a bunch of french people young at me in
french i'm like i don't know what what
you're saying i don't care what you're
saying it's irrelevant
now if they're coming out and they're
writing fake stories like the boston
children's hospital thing if you're
trying to you know obfuscate what's
really going on you got to call that out
that's like manipulation and lies with
hunter biden
you know dude this guy his laptop is
confirmed by multiple outlets the emails
are confirmed even the new york times
said it and a year and a half after the
fact oh and the media and and and big
tech suppressed the information because
well big tickets
yeah that's what they do like if you
look at this right now i just got sent
this
uh libs of tick tock facebook account
was just suspended for no reason at all
no reason at all and the big tech
companies are backing all of this yeah
and like their reaction to you know the
boston children's hospital story has and
like their reactions to a lot of similar
stories when it comes to
when it comes to the transgender issue
is literally insane like my friend jamie
michelle who runs an organization called
gays against groomers which is just like
you know they're they're kind of just a
media thing where a bunch of work
they're all gay and trans and they talk
about how they talk against like sex
changes for kids and they they speak out
against groomers and they had their
twitter account suspended today and
they've been you know shadow band was
instagrammed was it reinstated it was
reinstated like right before the show
yeah this reinstated but i wonder if uh
lips of tick tock will have any recourse
like that with facebook but they have
they're going after libs of tiktok hard
for this too like there have been there
i've seen so many you know woke
journalists who have been saying why
hasn't twitter suspended libs have take
out tick tock yet for posting things
that this hospital is posting on their
youtube channel you know what i was
thinking um we talked about this before
that this issue didn't exist prior to
the advent of widespread hormonal uh
treatments or the isolation of the
hormones in general so you know i've
talked some people like where where was
this issue 100 years ago well there was
no isolated hormone i think they did
like serotonin first so you couldn't
take
any anything to to change your body well
and then they turned it turned out that
the ssris are bogus anyway well so the
argument was that uh
trans people have always existed
but they were just extremely depressed
uncomfortable in their bodies and it
wasn't a public issue because no one
knew with the advent of hormonal
therapies these people were now having
access and this issue emerges there's
also and i wanted to i just wanted to
point out
what that means if if the reason the
issue exists is because the medical
technology has emerged to allow it to
exist in this form then once we get to
like dna splicing viruses there's gonna
be people who are like i want to be a
cat yeah and they're gonna start taking
pills that start cutting their body
there are people who want to do that
like you see that there's people who get
like a full body
modification to be cat looking or to be
like like who's that the
i don't know i'm not comic book person
but there's the guy who got fully
changed to be like the red death guy
yeah and like a red skull yeah and his
nose totally done if you look it up wow
there he is or there's the lady the lady
who became looking exactly like a barbie
doll with the exact barbie um yeah it's
it's proportions including like the
crazy eye thing and hair extensions and
the boobs and the whole thing i mean
people can use this
medical frankenstein technology to do
whatever they want and the doctors who
go along with it
uh have really found their sweet spot
with the whole trans thing because they
can do it without having to feel bad
about performing medical experiments on
people
i think there's all there is also i
think a major major cultural aspect to
it as well
because like if you look at you know
there are studies about with the
percentage of people in specific
generations that identify as lgbt
and in like the younger generations it's
at like 15 20 it's like 30 and it's like
it's like it's grown from like two
percent in the silent generation to like
20 today like did that happen because
i don't think that happened by accident
i think i'm just trying to bring up that
like
where this goes from here
is you know not not to rehash things
that we've we talked about the previous
segment something different and that is
we're we're going to develop new
technologies you know people like hunter
biden who's got dysmorphia or whatever
oh he's gonna take a pill that's gonna
you know
enlarge himself things like that people
are gonna do it like crazy people are
going to start doing designer gene
therapies on their kids so like
we've talked about i mean i'm assuming
you guys have seen gatica
we're gonna get to the point where it's
just like
why have your kid with bad eyes why have
your kid have bad hair why have your kid
with uh with your kid should be six foot
five and then we're going to just
homogenize everybody well and then if
your parents can't afford to have you be
recreated as some extra smart person
you're just going to be
way down below everybody else
taxpayers to pay for it and make it
mandatory or like optionally that's what
they're doing with the with the
surgeries on or what biden's trying to
do is make that make it tax funded yes
that's right
and that's why and desantis was like no
medicaid will not be funding this in
florida and in canada like canada a lot
i don't know if this is a federal law in
canada but a lot of canadian provinces
have laws where if you don't respect
your child's identity the state can take
your child away from that that is
federal and part of that has to do with
the conversion therapy ban that was put
into law by the trudeau liberals so
basically they redefined conversion
therapy and biden has taken a cue from
you know pretty boy justin up there um
and what they've done is they've said if
you do not affirm your child's identity
if you in fact say hey daughter you're
actually my daughter
then that is conversion therapy and that
is illegal and and that happened in
texas too like remember that story in
texas jeffrey younger jeffrey younger he
was a kid he was a kid who
in
a court ruled that his father was like
no longer like he didn't younger was the
dad yeah yeah the jeffrey he got custody
of his son taken away from him because
he wouldn't affirm his identity as a
girl meanwhile he had evidence that his
son was being like i'd rather wear boy
clothes yeah it was all his his mom just
like being totally inside being totally
insane thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you